you're expecting baby number two yeah
I'm ready to pop it's going to be a boy
for Holly Madison the former Girls Next
Door star and husband Pasquale Rotella
are already parents to three year old
rainbow Aurora does she know that she is
gonna be a big sister she does she's
finally accepted it at first I was like
you're getting a brother and she's like
no I want a sister I'm like no it's a
brother she's like I didn't do it is she
helping you pick out names at all
well the name she picked out with
strawberry so I don't think I'll go with
that but my husband and I are still
trying to decide okay it will it be a
name that's maybe more Disney themed at
all
my name's were thinking about her kind
of boring really yeah we're kind of
waiting for that last-minute epiphany
for a name to come to us that's perfect
do you want to have any more kids after
your son is born yeah I mean we'll see
how this one behaves but a husband wants
a lot of kids so we'll see how many if
you could he's like let's have six I'm
like you're up cadet adopting some
because I don't know if I can make the
small outfit would be up for that though
yeah over time yeah you know one day be
like a grandma with some kids and
grandkids but don't expect the 36 year
olds family to hit the small screen but
you guys ever do a family reality show
no I don't think so because I look at
these reality shows and I see so many
marriage does not make it and these
reality shows thrive on drama so I don't
want to start something where I feel
like I have to start drama in my
relationship and I wouldn't want my
daughter feeling like it's normal to
have cameras following her around all
the time
Holly happy and settled now but she
writes all about her dating escapades
before she met her husband in her new
book the Vegas Diaries did you get any
phone calls from these men after the
book came out no because I think I did a
really good job disguising them I
actually had some close friends of mine
read the book and they're like who are
you talking about I don't even know yeah
you're gonna change somebody's identity
you really have to go there